بعدما غدى حديث وسائل التواصل الاجتماعي
اثراء تهنئته لخطيبته رجوى السيد بمناسبه
ذكرى عيد ميلادها الذي صادف الجمعه الماضي
اطل ولي العهد الاردني بمفاجاه جديده
[موسيقى]
فقد كشف الامير الحسين بن عبد الله الثاني
ان موعد زفاته على خطيبته رجوى السيف
اقترب متحدثا عن الطريقه التي تعرفها على
بعضهما ورد ولي العهد الاردني الامير
الحسين على سؤال لاحد المشاركين في الجلسه
الحواريه التي شارك فيها في منتدى تواصل
الذي نظمته مؤسسه ولي العهد بالعاصمه
الاردنيه عمان كيف تعرف على خطيبته رجوى
متابع كيف تعرفت على
هذا السؤال الله يسامحك عن السبب هذا
السؤال بصراحه بنساله كثير فما تخاف لا
احد الحمد لله قصتنا بسيطه يعني انا كان
عندي زميله في المدرسه صاحبه رجوى
وتعرفت على رجوه من خلالها يعني وعلى فكره
على فكره ما حكينا او شفنا بعض لفتره بعد
ما تعرفنا وكان في يوم هيك اشي يذكرني
فيها قررت اسال عنها سبحان الله صار نصيب
والله
بعتبر حالي محظوظ لانه مش كل يوم الواحد
تعرف على حاجه زي
واكد ولي العهد بحضور خطيبته لجلسه
المنتدى وبحضور رئيس الوزراء الدكتور بشر
الخصاونه وعددا من الوزراء انه هو الانسه
رجوى يشعران بالراحه والامتصاص اي العرس
قرب
يعني الحمد لله مرتاحين ومتحمسين
والله يبارك فيك ونتمنى السعاده والفرح
الجميع
[موسيقى]